So for the VLIW let's discuss the good and the bad sides of it.
Among the good things is that the compiler does the hard work.
Because the compiler is run only once and then we run the program many times
the compiler can have plenty of time to figure out a good schedule. In contrast,
in an out of order processor we have very little time to come up with a decent
schedule because any time we spend figuring out the schedule is the time
we're adding to the program execution time. The VLIW processor typically will
have simpler hardware than a comparable out of order processor.
A VLIW processor can be more efficient than an out of order processor because
the hardware had less to do per executed instruction. And the VLIW
processors typically work really well on loops and so called regular code,
where regular code is basically things like sweeping to arrays,
multiplying matrices, and other things that a compiler can easily figure out and
then schedule well around it.
The bad side of VLIW are that latencies of instructions are not always the same.
The compiler has to assume some sort of latency in order to schedule code well,
but sometimes the latencies cannot be determined exactly. So
for example, we can plan for a load to have a cache hit latency but
then when it has a cache miss suddenly there is a much longer latency than
the compiler planned for. Second, many applications are irregular,
almost every application that does a lot of decision making, like for
example A.I. applications, applications that work on pointers or pointer
intensive structures and so on, are very hard for the compiler to figure out.
And finally there is the code bloat issue. We have already seen in our quiz,
that the code for a VAW can be much larger than the code for a normal,
out of order processor. Because we are inserting a lot of NOPs to prevent things
that are dependent on each other from being in the same large instruction.